yes what's up this is andrew for
tradingsenses.com so in this video guys
i want to change a little bit and i'm
here to make a full analysis on spy in
triple q the global market let's see
what is happening there let's get into
it
[Music]
oh right guys so spy triple q guys as
every week for the past two three weeks
i'm gonna keep doing that because it's
very important actually you know if you
don't know what is the global market
doing it's very hard to trade stocks i'm
you know trading stocks on uh this code
and right now i'm just waiting right
because you know i mean i take some
positions but
i don't go you know with big sizes and
like huge positions because the global
market is telling me that we are in a
corrective phase all right and that it's
not over and that we're going to see a
lot of fake outs in both directions on
the upside on the downside so buying
breakouts in this situation is not good
i mean not right now i'm going to tell
you when i think is the time and to know
when it's the time guys we need to pay
attention to volume all right so this is
what i want to emphasize in this video
i'm going to show you how i use volume
to get information about what is the
market doing and once again guys i'm not
going to do the full speech here but i'm
building a course guys that is amazing
with like some content that you won't
find anywhere yes because it's based on
my experience i've been working that
course for the past six months guys it's
really really really good i believe that
and if you don't like it you're fully
refunded so if you want to be part of
this project guys just subscribe on the
link click on the link in the
description of this video and you're
gonna receive a 50 discount to when the
course is going to be released within
one or two weeks so let's go back to
what i was saying volume guys so how can
we here
use the volume so all right i'm using
some media wave theory but to be honest
eliot with theory is very useful once
you understand how to use the major
price action dynamics volume volatility
momentum if you don't know that i mean
any other theory is not gonna help you
you're just gonna you're not gonna know
where are the waves when is you know
breakouts are helping you to know when
the wave is complete all right here for
example this was the signal the a the a
wave was complete okay this because i
have a breakout here so if you don't
know when there is a short-term reversal
you don't know when the wave is complete
so you're going to put your waves just
randomly and it's not going to be
useful so whatever here i have some
idiotic counting but actually i don't
use it much for now what i'm paying
attention to is the volume so once again
we had this first move down so as you
can see guys this was the
beginning of a correction with a strong
volume increase okay then we had this
fake out situation that i told you would
happen these bull traps that are coming
very often when we have this strong
rebound all right
so here the fake out occurred guys once
again on extremely low volume as you can
see i just want to check it here
okay you see the volume is here so it's
one of the lowest volume we had trading
so of course this is not a good trading
signal we've been through that already
and right now what is happening we are
in the c wave i believe so what can we
expect in terms of volume first is it is
the volume going to be bigger during a c
wave or a wave
good question
so to answer that i would say that it
depends most likely the volume is going
to be bigger during the a wave when
there is a lot of panic okay because we
are starting a correction and during a c
wave you're still going to have some
volume increase
but at the end of the c wave you're
going to have a very low volume period
that is
preceding a reversal okay before
reversal you have low volume keep that
in mind so we expect
that the volume
increases
somewhere in the middle of the sea wave
but then then it gets really low all
right if we come here i'm not sure we're
gonna come here it's my scenario uh so i
believe we're gonna come here but of
course i'm not sure and i want to see a
volume like here like here you know
those low volume and if i see that okay
the slow volume here
then it will make me confident that a
reversal is gonna come and i'm probably
gonna start to buy here if i see that we
come here with massive volume
okay
then i know that we are in a coveted
crisis mode all right
let's check how it was you see
so this is
the covet crisis a b c but the
difference guys is this all right
a b with the usual bull trap c
but look at that
volume increase all right so
the situation is a bit different guys
it's a crisis so we can see we have the
volume increase
until the end but usually during
corrections that are not crisis you have
a volume decrease at the end of the
correction and then
you know here we add the volume decrease
only here
[Music]
okay so this was a good signal for
example to enter all right buying here
was dangerous because you have a
breakout true
but with no volume increase but
it's understandable because there was so
much such a huge volume trading before
during the crisis
then it makes it harder to have a volume
increase
even
when you have a good breakout so
whatever what i wanted to show you guys
here i don't want to give you too much
information
in the same time once again in my course
guys i take this step by step it's eight
hours of video guys 33 videos where i
explained this very well guys so if
you're interested just come here
here i need to go quickly guys it's
short videos you know it's youtube what
i wanted to say is that yeah we expect
uh
the the volume to get lower at the end
of the sea wave okay we're gonna be
monitoring that for sure but so what do
we expect now during it so i think we're
in the seawave once again
after the years last week that
we will correct again and we did
monday was bullish okay tuesday was uh
no monday was so so
tuesday was bullish wednesday was
bullish as well and then thursday friday
bearish so the week was bearish if i
checked the weekly time frame you know
we we lost 1.5 percent we had a bearish
week so i'm still saying we're gonna
we're gonna have one more bearish week
this time i think we're going to
accelerate so as you can see the volume
is slowly starting to increase
but it's much smaller than what it was
during the beginning of the wave so this
is looking like a typical c wave to me
not very risky but if i see
for example here i reduced a little bit
my shot position for those one discord
with me you saw that
if i see too many days with low volume
then it's also saying that maybe the c
wave is not a c wave and it's a one two
okay we need to be prepared for this
alternative scenario which is possible
guys is that the correction is actually
over the abc is here it's possible yes
everything is possible in trading and if
you're not prepared for the alternative
scenario this is when you might lose
money and sometimes a lot okay so be
prepared for everything it's possible
that it's a one two and that we get a
three all right if we have a three here
coming guys the volume is going to
increase with green days so we're gonna
see that we're gonna know that this
correction is over for now yeah so i was
saying that here we had those two low
volume days and if i see too many of
those
when basically nothing is happening it's
telling me that
the sea wave might not be a sea wave so
i'm paying attention to that for example
if next week we start to pause here like
that
and we consolidate the whole week
this looks very much like
this is not a c wave okay so the more
days with low volume where nothing
happens right now
uh happen uh the more we can say that
this scenario is not the right one and
it's a one two if we go on the downside
and we see that we go on the downside
with volume that are bigger but not
bigger than at the beginning this is
telling us that this is a normal sea
wave and that we need to buy between
four or five and four fifteen
now if we see that we come to four
fifteen four five with a volume that is
bigger than that
guys
this is bad i don't think this will
happen but if i see that i'm gonna be
here to tell you don't worry that this
is bad and that we should not buy it
here all right this would be a
massive bull trap okay so don't worry
i'm not i'm gonna be here guys to tell
you what i think will happen everything
will be all right i'm very confident
that the sea wave is not too deep but
everything is possible you have russia
ukraine that might enter war guys so
this is you know some big things we have
inflation that is coming guys i mean not
coming that is here rates are going to
increase so we have a lot of things that
might tell us that this here might be a
bit bloody but my preferred scenario is
just that we have some
we did two here then we have some ups
ups and down and then finally
maybe in maybe later guys maybe this is
a little bit too bullish maybe something
like that in june
september we start to be really bullish
again guys and i'm gonna be here to buy
this market so that's it for me guys i
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did please don't forget to click on the
sub like and bell button so you're gonna
be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to shore
i'll see you guys